the boy and the Beast is directed by
Mamoru Hosoda who's previously brought
us the Digimon movie as well as the girl
who lived through time summer Wars wolf
children and now the boy and the beast
this guy is quickly becoming my favorite
director working in animation and now
that hi Miyazaki has retired I actually
think he is my favorite director working
in animation and just let you know up
front I'm gonna be telling you guys at
the end of this video about something
I'm doing with lootcrate right now I
thank them very much for sponsoring this
video I'll talk to you guys about that
afterwards a young boy named Ren has run
away from his family after a tragic
accident and when he stumbles across a
strange alleyway in the middle of the
city he discovers a portal that leads to
the beast world in which everyone who
inhabits this area is some sort of
animal and they can all walk and talk
and they have lives and this is where he
runs into this large bear like man who's
training for something called u10 guy
it's this tournament where you can
become a lord if you win and then you
earn the right to reincarnate into
whatever you want to be but the movies
really about this boy and this beast
training with one another the beast is
supposed to be the master and the young
boy the apprentice but in reality it
becomes kind of blurred because they
both help each other in life this was a
gorgeous phenomenal movie I love this
movie I like this film so much that
after seeing it one of the first
showings in the afternoon by myself I
told my wife how much I loved it and we
went back and saw it again the exact
same day and it didn't drag it all I saw
it twice in the same day this is a
marvelous animation as far as I'm
concerned this is the best weekend I've
ever experienced in my entire life for
animation films with Zootopia and now
this both in the same weekend this is
amazing not only is the animation itself
so beautiful but there are so many
themes woven throughout this movie about
darkness friendship and Parenthood and
there are also so many small hidden
moments that I didn't notice the first
time I saw it that become important as
the film plays on and I was so happy
that I went and saw it a second time
because I actually ended up liking it
more the second time the first time I
saw it I was wondering what this film is
going to be for like the first 20 to 30
minutes it didn't show itself for a
while if you know what I mean it's a
film that really sneaks up on you the
emotions behind this move
we are very well-hidden and once the
movie really lets you know what it's
actually going to be about and the
themes that are present throughout the
film I was blown away this movie floored
me the only issue I have with it is it
sometimes it gets exposition heavy this
is a problem with anime a lot of times
anime just they like hey just in case
you didn't know
bla bla bla bla bla bla bla here's a
bunch of stuff that you need to know it
happens and with this film there's a lot
of it and sometimes you need to know
certain things because it's important to
understand the characters but I think
they could have chosen slightly more
clever ways of letting us know this
information this is an emotionally
touching film with spectacular action
set-pieces
very very good animation and I wish to
the bottom of my heart that more films
like this were made in America mature
animations with deep emotional themes
that can actually impact you don't miss
this movie if it's playing in a theater
near you I highly recommend it go seek
it out I'm going to give the boy in the
Beast and a so as I said loot crate is
doing something very cool this March
that is the vs. crate and a lot of
things inside this amazing geek
awesomeness box that can be sent to you
is Batman V Superman in March it's going
to have stuff for alien vs. predator as
well as daredevil vs. punisher and if
you sign up at loot crate calm slash
Chris stuckman before March 19th you can
get the vs. crate definitely check that
out the link is in the description below
if you want to click on it thank you so
much guys as always for watching please
don't miss out on the blowin the Beast
it is definitely an animation worth your
time I can't wait to see it again and I
saw it twice in one day which I really
don't ever do thank you so much as
always for watching stay tuned on Sunday
Superman 64 retro rewind happily it's
gonna be fun I can't wait to share that
with you guys thank you as always for
watching you guys are the best and if
you like this you can click right here
and get stuck mine eyes
you